today's video is sponsored by call of
war
do you ever wonder what kind of leader
would i be
if i was in charge of a whole country
well
wonder no more because with the free
online pvp strategy game
call of war you get to choose a real
country to lead during world war ii it
requires you to use a variety of
different
units such as tanks and planes as well
as other secret weapons
in order to build your army you can play
with the same account
on both pc and mobile it's such great
fun and the thing i love most about the
game is the long term strategy element
i'm giving my viewers a special gift if
you click on the link below
you'll get 13 000 goals and one month of
premium subscription
for free and you can even join my custom
game by entering my custom game id and
password
after you sign up using my special link
in the description
i'll reveal my custom game details at
the end of the video
so be sure to stick around hey 42 here
on the 17th of august 1987
a frail 93 year old man unplugged a lamp
from the table in his
summer house then lifted the extension
cord with his trembling arthritic
fingers
and began patiently winding it around
the latch of a nearby window
when he was satisfied the cord was
secure
he made a loop at the other end placed
that loop around his neck
and allowed himself to slide slowly to
the floor
pulling the makeshift noose tight around
his neck
and cutting off the air supply to his
lungs
within minutes he was dead
if you're wondering why this ancient man
had decided to take such drastic action
i can confirm it wasn't an act of erotic
asphyxiation
gone wrong and neither was it an
accident although some people believe it
may have been a murder
made to look like a suicide but before
we get into all of that
perhaps it would be helpful if i told
you exactly who this particular
oap was because what i've just described
were the final earthly actions
of a man named rudolf hess husband
father keen gardener avid hiker
oh and one time second in command to a
guy called adolf hitler
hess was so notorious that at the time
of his suicide
he was the sole inmate in a 600 cell
fortress prison presided over by a cadre
of guards
from the uk france the united states
and the soviet union representatives
from these countries would take it in
turn to guard hess
rotating personnel from one month to the
next
for an idea of how much effort and
expense went into guarding this
one man just picture the prison that
houses tai lung
in the first kung fu panda film and
you're pretty much there
almost as soon as hess was found dead
the entire prison that held him
was raised to the ground so as not to
become a shrine to neo-nazis
but before it was unceremoniously
demolished
the prison was known as spandau and it
was located in western berlin
at the end of world war ii a series of
court proceedings known as the norenberg
trials took place
to determine the fate of high-ranking
nazis
many were sentenced to death by hanging
a handful were acquitted
but seven of them including rudolf hess
ended up serving prison sentences of
varying glimpse in spandau
by the way if the name spandau is
ringing a bell
you might be thinking of the british new
wave pop group the spandau ballet
and oddly enough the band did indeed get
its name from the prison that housed
rudolf hess
and other prominent nazis specifically
the name refers to the involuntary jig
danced by spandau inmates in their death
froze
during execution by hanging lovely name
for a band that
anyway whilst hess was the last of the
spandau 7 to leave the prison
and the only one that did so in a
bodybag he was
also the first of them to be captured
you see
unlike his fellow inmates who were
rounded up at the end of the war
hesse had already been in prison in
britain for some four years at that
point
and the story of how he ended up there
is quite possibly the strangest ever to
come out of the second world war
it starts with a friendship bordering on
obsession
with one of the most evil men in history
includes a secret solo flight to
scotland across war-torn europe
and ends in one of the longest prison
sentences
ever served by a human being
allow me to explain despite being a
fierce patriot and
nationalist rudolf hess was actually
born in
egypt and wouldn't make germany his
permanent home
until the age of 14 when he went to
boarding school there
he was 20 by the time the first world
war broke out
and having signed up pretty much
straight away he served germany with
distinction
fighting in the first battle of ipra and
the battle of verdun
during which time he earned both a
bullet through his lung
and an iron cross second class
the war ended when hess was 24 and much
like every other soldier
he went home and tried to build a life
for himself
but one evening in july of 1920
this unfamiliar new existence took a
decisive turn
because that night rudolf hess heard
adolf hitler speak
in front of a crowd for the very first
time
hess had harbored racist views his
entire life
whilst growing up in egypt he'd shown
contempt for
everyone who wasn't white and he
believes
germany had lost the first world war
thanks to a widespread conspiracy
of jews and bolsheviks so it was no
surprise that he was drawn to hitler
like a big
racist moth to a bright bigoted flame
hess signed up to the nazi party that
very same night
from that point on he was rarely found
far from the future fiora's side
he acted as hitler's muscle at rallies
where clashes of ideology
frequently escalated into exchanges of
punches
and helped out with fundraising for the
party along with
pretty much anything else that needed
doing when hitler attempted to seize
control
first of munich and then the german
national government
during what is now known as the beer
hall puts
in 1923 hess was once again
by his side the coup failed and both
hitler
and hess were sent to prison for five
years
but even behind bars hess managed to
keep himself useful to the man he saw
as the future of his nation scribing and
editing for hitler
as he dictated what would become the
foundation
of the nazi party manifesto mein kampf
to say hess was at the center of the
nazi party during these formative years
would be akin to claiming heroin is a
tad moorish
it's true it's just one hell of an
understatement
hess was a fanatical follower of
hitler's ideology
and unlike plenty of other nazis he
wasn't in it for the glory
or the power but just because he
believed
and through his belief and his devotion
to hitler
he became one of the most important
figures in the fuhrer's rise
the silent bob to hitler's jay
the bird to his ernie the
wait is it just me or is rudolf hess
actually the spitting image of bert well
that's something
i'm never going to be able to unsee
anyway
despite literally trying to overthrow
the government of their own country
hitler and hess were released from
prison after serving less than a year
behind bars
and around 10 years after that hitler
achieved his ultimate goal
of becoming the leader of the german
branch this time
through the slightly more mainstream
method of actually getting people to
vote for him
within the year his power in germany was
absolute
but despite having hit the big time
hitler remembered his old friend
hess repaying his enduring loyalty
by honoring him with the title of deputy
fuhrer
and eventually going as far as to make
her second in line to the leadership of
the entire nazi party
behind hermann goring the supreme
commander of the luftwaffe
as for hess he couldn't have been
happier the man
he viewed as something close to
germany's messiah
was in power the country he loved was
back on the road to greatness after the
shame of its defeat in the great war
and hess himself was right in the thick
of it
as one of hitler's most trusted
confidants
but as war descended across europe in
things began to change despite his
military record hesse's main duties
weren't directly related to the war
effort
and as hitler became more and more
distracted with blitzkrieg tactics and
complex foreign policy for the first
time
since 1920 hess found himself
on the outside of hitler's inner circle
looking in
as the war progressed he began to grow
more and more worried
it wasn't so much that things were going
badly quite the opposite in fact
by the middle of 1940 germany controlled
much of europe
poland norway denmark belgium luxembourg
the netherlands half of france but these
early successes
had gone to hitler's head the germans
and their allies were starting to get
cocky this growing sense of
invincibility
in the nazi camp was one of the driving
forces behind
operation barbarossa hitler's plan
to invade the soviet union
but hesse was concerned that taking on
both
the allies and the soviet union who up
until now had largely stayed out of
things
and in some cases actively worked with
the germans was just
asking for trouble hess felt that trying
to fight against the british and the
soviets simultaneously
would stretch german resources to fit
and so whilst hitler and his cronies
were putting the finishing touches to
their plans
for operation barbarossa hess
was finalizing a plan all of his own
one that no one not even the fuhrer
ever saw coming hess's scheme
was simple he reasons that if fighting
on two fronts
had the potential to be a military
disaster all he had to do
was remove one of germany's enemies from
the equation
and so rudolf hess was going to take the
british
out of world war ii on his own
but if you're picturing bert from sesame
street dressed in full rambo
regalia storming the houses of
parliament in search of winston
churchill
you're a little wide of the mark hess
didn't plan to defeat the british in
battle
he was going to neutralize them at the
negotiating table
by suing for peace and how exactly he
attempted to do that
is without a doubt one of the single
weirdest things to have happened in the
whole of the second world war
hess an accomplished pilot secretly had
a messerschmitt modified
with long-range fuel tanks and several
other updates
to equip it for long distance flying
he trains tirelessly in the aircraft for
many months
focusing on his navigation skills and
efficient flying techniques
and then one night in the spring of 1941
as war raged across europe and the
german luftwaffe
prepared for a huge bombing grade on
london
the deputy fuhrer second in line to the
command of the entire nazi party
took off from an airfield in the south
of germany
all on his own and set a course
for scotland now then
this is probably the part of the story
where i should point out
that hess may have been a little bit
mad rumor has it this whole wild scheme
came to him in a dream
and he chose the date of his departure
based on the advice
of his astrologer who had a good
feeling about the alignment of a couple
of planets and stuff
apparently feeling he no longer had the
furious trust
hess plans this crazed mission entirely
alone
and without informing nazi leadership
hoping to hand hitler the keys to peace
with britain
before anyone even realized he was
missing
still mad or otherwise hess
knew how to handle an aeroplane he flew
solo
over largely unfamiliar terrain in foggy
weather
and with only charts and maps for
guidance
all whilst avoiding british air defenses
and
more than one raf squadron sent to
intercept him he flew much of the latter
part of the journey at an altitude of
just 15 meters
in order to better avoid british fighter
pilots
hesse's destination was dungavel house
home of the duke of hamilton whom hess
understood
was keen on peace with germany and had
the power to help broker it
hess never quite made it though his
master class in navigation
and evasive flying didn't quite get him
to his destination
because he ran out of fuel just 12 miles
away
forcing him to bail out of his
messerschmitt
and parachute to safety a local man
found him not too long after
still struggling to extricate himself
from his shoot
in a field just outside the village of
waterfoot
south of glasgow hess assuming the false
name
alfred horn asked to be taken straight
to see the duke of hamilton
but this was britain so instead of doing
as hess
asked instinct kicked in and the man
who'd found him
followed the single most important rule
in the great british manual of
etiquette he took hess home to his
cottage
and made him a nice cup of tea
hess was eventually allowed to meet with
hamilton
but after revealing his true identity
and explaining his mission he soon
encountered a problem
common to many foreigners visiting
scotland
hess spoke fluent english and had no
difficulty getting his point across
the only trouble was he couldn't
understand a damn thing
hamilton was saying in response a
translator was sent for to turn
hamilton's english into
more english but it soon became clear
hess's problems didn't end with
hamilton's
incomprehensible scottish accent the
duke had neither the power
nor the inclination to make peace with
germany
so less than 24 hours in hesse's grand
mission
was a failure even worse because he'd
made it clear
he wasn't acting under the orders of
hitler and was therefore
not in scotland as part of an official
envoy
instead of being sent back to germany as
a diplomat
hess was thrown in jail not that anyone
really knew what to do with him once
they put him there
hamilton himself rang winston churchill
to explain this strange turn of events
but the prime minister found the idea of
hitler's right-hand man
parachuting into a small village in
scotland all on his lonesome
to negotiate peace so ridiculous
he assumed hamilton was playing an
ill-conceived joke
on him and hung up back in germany
hitler wasn't finding the situation
particularly funny either
when word got back to him about his
deputies impromptu highland holiday
hitler is said to have let out an
animalistic roar
that shook the walls of his mountain
home before decreeing that if hess
ever returned to germany he would be
shot on site
not that hess needed to worry about that
he would never be allowed to return home
at least not as a free man after his
capture in 1941 he would spend the rest
of his long life
as a prisoner during the war he was held
in various different facilities
across the uk including a brief spell in
the tower of london
becoming the last state prisoner ever to
be held there
and the last prisoner full stop aside
from notorious london gangsters
the cray twins who spent a few days
there in 1952
hesse's 46 years as a prisoner
represents one of the longest sentences
ever served in history the 32nd
longest outside of the u.s according to
wikipedia
and the last 20 years of his term was
spent in complete solitary confinement
not as a punishment for bad behavior but
because
as i've already mentioned he was the
only inmate left in the entire prison at
the time
from almost a moment he was captured
hess showed signs of the extreme
paranoia
and superstition that have led many
people over the years to question his
sanity
he was obsessed with the idea his
captors were trying to poison him
often refusing meals or insisting on
swapping plates with his guards before
eating
he also believed in all sorts of extreme
conspiracy theories
including that both churchill and hitler
were under the control of psychic jews
in just a couple of weeks on the 10th of
may it will be 80 years
to the day since rudolf hess's flight
yet still today this strange story of
one man's attempts to alter the course
of the war
remains so bizarre many people believe
there must be more to it than meets the
eye
one popular theory suggests hitler knew
all about the
apparently solo mission but that it was
agreed up front
if hess was ever captured he would be
disavowed and branded a madman
so as not to damage morale back in
germany
in 2011 german newspaper der spiegel
reported on the recovery of a statement
written in a soviet concentration camp
by hesse's personal aid which did appear
to suggest
the fiora had been fully aware of hess's
mission
though there's no guarantee the report
wasn't coerced
especially considering where it was
written
another theory suggests hess was
actively lured into making the trip
by the british secret service he posed
as a duke of hamilton
in a series of letters in an attempt to
trick hess
into coming to britain again treads of
evidence seem to back this story up
but none are in any way conclusive
for a long time one of the more
persistent conspiracies surrounding the
case
was that hess never actually made the
journey at all
and that an imposter had flown in his
place
this theory was put forward by british
army surgeon hugh thomas
who on giving hess a medical exam found
no trace of the bullet wound hesse had
suffered in world war one
according to thomas the single inmate
serving out his years in spandau prison
was not and never had been rudolf hess
this story persisted all the way up
until 2019
when dna testing of an old sample of
hess's blood
was shown to have a 99.99
match in y chromosomal dna with one of
hesse's living relatives
most of the conspiracy theories
surrounding hess are speculative at best
but there is still something of an air
of mystery to the whole story
and whilst the majority of classified
documents from the second world war
have long since been released into the
public domain
one small cache has been held back far
longer than most and believe it or not
it's reported to contain correspondence
between hess
and none other than king george vi
himself
conspiracy theorists believe these files
may uncover a plot within the british
monarchy
to ditch winston churchill and make
peace with germany
back when things weren't looking so good
for europe at the start of the
war the files are due to be released 20
years from now by the way
on the 100th anniversary of the flight
which is probably for the best the royal
family could do with a few quiet years
as for hess's ultimate demise at the age
of 93
even that has attracted some whispers is
it really possible that a very old
very frail man could have hanged himself
and why would he have even wanted to
after so long behind bars it's true that
he tried
and failed to take his own life many
times over the years
but some people still believe he was
eventually bumped off by the british
who were worried about what secrets he
might spill if released
it's a big claim but there were a few
odd inconsistencies relating to his
death
most notably the fact the apparent
suicide note
found beside the body had actually been
written after hess
feared dying when admitted to hospital
with a perforated ulcer
in 1969 still
that certainly isn't proof and if it
really was a secret service hit
it seems mighty incompetent of them to
have attempted to pass off
a 20-year-old letter as a suicide note
as for what really compelled rudolph
hess to risk the dangerous
and undeniably daring flight from
germany to scotland
in the middle of the second world war
that's open for debate
was he simply someone standing on the
very edge of sanity
making a wild play to regain the favor
of the man he worshipped
or was he on a secret mission from the
fuhrer himself
to broker peace with the british in a
move that
if successful could have changed the
entire course of the
war and therefore the history of mankind
maybe or perhaps it had just been far
far too long since he'd had a good
haggis
[Music]
thanks for watching thanks again to call
of war for sponsoring this video
and remember you can claim your
exclusive gift by clicking the link in
the description
this offer is only available for 30 days
so choose your country
and fight your way to victory